9 il n'y aura pas de réformes monory si
le ministre de l'éducation nationale ne
veut pas de grands changements pour
l'école il préfère procéder par petits
pas ainsi pour ces projets d'aménagement
du rythme scolaire et de changement des
séries du baccalauréat il va les
soumettre aux personnes concernées en
particulier les enseignants et les
décisions définitives seront prises
ensuite début décembre
rené monory explique que son souci
premier est la santé des enfants et
qu'en plus il entend répondre aux
exigences d'une société moderne
gérard pas son lâchage des vacances
sonnera un peu plus souvent que par le
passé
les enfants surtout les plus jeunes ont
besoin de quatre et même de 5 oz est
parti dans l'année pour 87 88 retour la
traditionnelle rentrée du 8 septembre et
rené monory propose huit jours à la
toussaint quinze jours à noël
dix jours en février quinze jours à
pâques et cinq jours à la pentecôte 7/5
petite pause viendrait donc compensé le
léger raccourcissement des vacances de
toussaint et de pâques reste donc
inchangé les 36 semaines de classe dont
les horaires au collège et au lycée
serait toutefois un peu allégé grâce à
l'utilisation réelle du mois de juin
les examens débuterait en effet
seulement le 21 juin et notamment les
épreuves du baccalauréat le bac pour
lequel rené monory a également des
projets beaucoup de jeunes
malheureusement c'est la société qui est
comme ça
devront se remettre en cause peut-être
plusieurs fois dans leur vie ils me
feront d'autant plus facilement qu'ils
seront sortis du système scolaire avec
une plusieurs général plus grandes
toques une spécialisation bien sûr pour
le bac avec 4 séries littéraires quatre
séries scientifiques mais sans
abandonner jusqu'au bac telle ou telle
matière qui pourrait leur servir plus
tard
ac 4 bac ès lettres et à ses 4 bac ès
sciences qui verrait donc le jour en
1990 ne pas oublier d'ajouter sur un
pied d'égalité les quelques 18 bac
technologique qui serait réparti eux
aussi en deux séries industrielles et
économiques
on le voit là non plus pas de révolution
pas petit pas parce que vous savez dès
qu'on prend une décision dans cette
maison compte tenu du nombre de
fonctionnaires du nombre d'enfants elle
a tout de suite des incidences
budgétaires extrêmement importante
regarder cette année on l'a revalorisé
un peu la fonction d'instituteur sa coût
de 860 millions je m'en réjouis mais ça
veut dire que chaque fois qu'on touche à
quelque chose
faut quand même regarder de l'autre côté
l'addition que ça peut ça peut provoquer
à côté de cette politique de